do you know why do you feel hungry  now you might be thinking your stomach  is growling and you're feeling hungry  but actually your hunger is controlled  by the hunger center so whenever our  stomach growls the hormone ghrelin is  secreted and it tells our brain to eat  more and our adipose tissue in  contrast secretes leptin  which actually tells us to eat less  inside our hunger center there are two  types of neurons or exogenic neuron or  eat more metabolize less neuron and  anorexigenic neuron which is eat less  and metabolize more neuron so the  adipose tissue derived leptin positively  regulates these anorexigenic neuron and  negatively regulates oxygenic neuron and  telling us not to eat now the stomach  derived ghrelin positively regulate or  exogenic neuron and it tells our brain  to eat more and now you know the basis  of hunger subscribe for more